because you know you think about quantum
right
as long as you say that there's an
uncertainty
and you have me believe there's an
uncertainty then there's uncertainty but
if there's not an uncertainty what
happens
so i'm only saying that it's not that
last because you look at quantum
computers they're going to give you the
oh
the one
the one the oh they're gonna get they're
gonna take two things and make it eight
things and by the time you multiply four
of those things together
it's like this chess board right
the moves goes into the millions
but
the thing that's introduced is the
uncertainty
right
you gonna make a move
this you know this already
right
because this has
been played a thousand times but sooner
or later something uncertain is going to
come in or make the next move
i like the weight of these
they add to add the certainty
i think it's just like we're saying
unpredictable that there's something
about uh us humans that really doesn't
like everything to be fully predictable
i mean chess two
is uh
perfectly solvable there's nothing
unpredictable about chess right well i
could agree to that because
bobby fischer said in one of his books
which i actually love what he said
he said every game of chess
is a draw
yeah
the only way somebody wins is when one
of us makes a mistake
i mean it doesn't get any better yeah it
doesn't
what is chess
like how do you think about chess what's
at the core of your interest in chess do
you see
kung fu
music film
all of it life all just living through
chess
yeah i see i it's the most stimulating
passage of time for me
that's also
it's like it's a pastime
that stimulates
my mind my music
my thoughts about life at the same time
so while some past times it's like say
baseball is watch it's a pastime and
baseball can stimulate you depending on
how you look at it right but most likely
you're not going to get
this much brain activation this much
calculation
and this much thinking about yourself
in the game of baseball be i mean the
player maybe but not the
viewer chess is something that i can
engage in to
and even though it's a pastime
it's giving me all the stimulation of
real time in my life
it's funny because it's also
it's a funny game because it's connected
through
centuries of play
just
some of the most interesting people in
the history of the world have played
this game and have struggled
with whatever have projected their
struggles onto the chessboard and
thought and the nations have fought over
the chessboard right right the soviet
union versus the united states bobby
fischer represented the united states
you